in this video I want to talk a little
bit about what alternative splicing is
alternative splicing otherwise known as
alternative processing the simple idea
of it is simply that we're taking the
same you can take the same mRNA
transcript and it can be sliced in
different ways now why is that
significant because this yields
different proteins from the same gene
one gene will give you one particular
mRNA transcript and then once you have
that mRNA transcript if you can splice
it in different ways those mature mRNAs
will be different and different mature
mRNAs will yield different protein
products so if we imagine this example
here this is a a pre mRNA here with its
five prime cap here and it's three prime
poly a tail here and each of these
little letters here ABC all the way
through H will represent exons so those
are the sequences that are supposed to
stay or supposed to end up in the mature
mRNA and then these number these Roman
numerals here represent introns which
will be cut out and they will not be in
the mature mRNA so this can be spliced
in a variety of ways I've only shown to
hear but if alternative splicing occurs
maybe we'll take out some exons and then
we'll yield it so that only exon a c e f
and g show up in the mature mrna and
then in the second case will have a b c
d e and h in our mature mrna then this
mRNA can then be translated and soaking
this one and though you different
proteins because they're different mRNAs
so the whole idea here is that these
same initial transcripts can yield
different mRNAs and different proteins
so why would this ever be useful well
because maybe in the in you know in your
kidney this might be the way the PM RNA
is spliced but in maybe your brain this
might be the way that mRNA transcript or
splice who knows so one thing I do want
to note here I've
these little pink stars above the three
prime holiday details is to note that
they have different poly gay sites
different poly sites so notice this one
is attached at the G and this one is
attached at the H so there may be
multiple poly a sites and that's what
allows for alternative processes even
happen because that you need to have
these three pi poly a tails attached I
hope that video was helpful and
understanding alternative processing one
last thing I am a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
maybe move University ID mail calm see
the description below for more details
thank you for watching